[Música]
num mundo onde o título
o mestrado o doutorado a pós graduação
são tão importantes e às vezes do
currículo lattes chega na frente da
pessoa
eu confesso que fico meio sem graça de
me apresentar diante de vocês aqui sem
apresentar nenhuma pós-graduação em um
mestrado nem doutorado mas pra evitar
esse constrangimento eu criei um título
pra chamar de meu e eu espero que depois
que eu apresentasse as minhas
credenciais
a minha fala vem com um pouquinho mais
de autoridade
senhoras e senhores eu sou especialista
na arte de errar lato sensu
tudo começou há muito tempo atrás e na
escola quando eu tinha uns oito para
nove anos mais ou menos e eu fui chamado
na lousa pra responder uma conta de
matemática uma multiplicação com dois
números
eu não achava muito bem do assunto mas
eu também não tinha medo de errar
então eu fui lá é bonito rei uma duas
três vezes na terceira vez que eu errei
a professora bo for virou o olho tomou
os dias da minha mão e respondeu com
raiva na lousa o jeito certo de fazer a
conta e o resultado dela eu nunca me
esqueci do resultado
e o resultado foi o seguinte desde então
eu nunca mais ser bom em matemática
mais do que isso aquilo foi um trauma na
minha vida eu passei a fugir dos números
como o diabo foge da cruz
e também naquele momento eu ouvia um
coro gritando dentro de mim que dizia oh
oh oh burro burro e desde então
eu toda vez que o ouço alguém falar em
números
parece que as pessoas estão falando um
outro idioma pra mim e aí o que me
sobrou me sobrou mundo das idéias nas
palavras da poesia
eu comecei a buscar refúgio nesse mundo
e aí eu me tornei o que as pessoas
costumam chamar de pessoas humanas
eu queria ser parte sexta
ser poeta eu queria mergulhar no mundo
das palavras e das idéias e aí pra
escolher a minha faculdade pela minha
relação com a poesia
eu decidi fazer letras mas meus amigos
falavam que eu devia fazer artes cênicas
porque eu era o colega de sala que
imitava os professores e aí quando eu
comecei a fazer letras eu tinha que
pagar a faculdade e foi trabalhar de
inspetor de alunos
e aí na escola pública de são bernardo
do campo e citando poesia para as
crianças do pátio às vezes visitando
algumas salas de aula eu fui convidado e
eu fui estimulado a desenvolver um
trabalho trabalho voluntário com aquelas
crianças conclusão
quando eu terminei a faculdade de letras
por eu sentia necessidade de desenvolver
ferramentas teatrais para aquele
trabalho
os meus amigos foram para a
pós-graduação e eu fui fazer teatro e é
por isso que não tem um título para
apresentar para vocês aqui hoje mas o
fato é que o teatro transformou o
professor que me tornei tempos depois eu
comecei a desenvolver a capacidade de
lidar com improviso com o jogo de
construir na cabeça dos meus alunos
o imaginário simbólico que era tão
importante além do fato de eu ser um
ator em sala de aula então às vezes eu
assumir algum personagem tudo mais e à
medida que eu fui me aprofundando neste
universo estudando teatro eu conhecia a
linguagem do palhaço e aí tudo mudou
porque não sei se vocês sabem mas o
palhaço é o mais humano dos artistas
pelo menos eu enxergo assim no circo
nós vemos pessoas fazendo coisas sobre
humanas
desafiando a lei da gravidade e o
palhaço é aquele que cai
o palhaço é aquele que erra é aquele que
falha e que se atrapalha e aquilo era
tão eu mesmo então menininho de humanas
qual a síndrome do cabeça de vento ou
não esquece a cabeça porque está grudada
eu sempre fui o menino que deixava os
cadastros amarrados e tropeçava nas
próprias pernas
eu sempre fui a criança que tapava
saindo para andar de bicicleta e voltava
com o joelho cotovelo ralado quando
tentava fazer uma manobra radical
eu sempre fui a criança que batia a cara
no poste que estava olhando pra alguma
coisa mais interessante
aquilo era muito eu era eu venho já era
muito palhaço mas como o professor não
né
como professor eu queria ser perfeito eu
queria ser certinho mas o que me
conectava com os meus alunos na verdade
era quando ele expressava a minha
vulnerabilidade
quando eu falava pessoal não tô legal
hoje eu preciso de ajuda
quando eu tropeçava derrubaram de vôlei
roubar alguma coisa gaguejava quando eu
fazia alguma coisa errada quando eu
sentado em falso na cadeira ou em casos
de extrema vulnerabilidade como o caso
da maçã perdida
vocês conhecem pessoas que foram vítimas
de bala perdida que eu fui vítima de uma
maçã perdida
eu estava no pátio com os meus alunos na
hora do recreio ou do recheio a parte
mais gostosa que fica no meio e eu
estava lá quando começou a guerra de
maçã
sobrou uma maçã para mim
pegou no olho arrebentou mil óculos em
show um pouco a diretoria veio falar
você pode ir na delegacia
eu falei eu só quero passar nas alas e o
que eu falei para os meus alunos foi o
seguinte
doeu aqui mas doeu muito mais aqui
porque eu tô lá embaixo porque eu gosto
de vocês meus amigos tiram sarro dessa
frase mas o que podia ter sido uma
experiência traumática na minha vida foi
uma das experiências mais bonitas que eu
já vivi porque depois disso no final do
período tinha mais de 200 alunos na
porta da minha sala para me abraçar
aquilo era vulnerabilidade aquilo era o
palhaço eu olhava para a escola e via as
situações como aquela violentas
eu via o imperfeito sem lugar eu se á às
pessoas que não se adequavam os próprios
padrões sofrendo
eu vi a escola doente e nesse momento eu
comecei a refletir sobre o trabalho dos
palhaços do hospital e me veio a
seguinte pergunta se tem palhaço do
hospital porque não tem palhaço na
escola se às vezes de uma escola é tão
doente quanto um quarto de uti e aí é
preciso
[Aplausos]
e foi aí que resolvi voltar para a
matemática e aí eu fiz uma conta
eu peguei a figura do palhaço mas a do
professor mas a do aluno que não entende
a matéria sobretudo e dividir por três
o resultado foi uma nova profissão
a dor palhaço apren de dor
o único profissional da educação que é
comprometido com o erro e que é pago pra
aprender e aí desde então eu visito as
salas de aula
sentando pra vivenciar a aprendizagem
com as crianças a partir do caminho do
erro
e aí eu tenho percebido o quanto a
escola trata o erro como um pecado como
é demonizado
eu acho que o erro deveria ser celebrado
lógico uma resposta certa ela é uma
conquista ela deve ser valorizada mas
que tal a gente olhar o erro por uma
outra perspectiva e pensar que ele pode
ser um passo em direção à aprendizagem e
não uma perda e não uma vergonha
as crianças hoje em dia tem medo de
errar medo de errar traçar o medo de
arriscar e traz há o medo de aprender
pra mim o medo de errar é uma doença
degenerativa tão grave quanto muitas
outras
e talvez essa doença foi curada a gente
consiga encontrar a cura para doenças
muito mais graves como câncer por
exemplo
e aí eu visito as escolas e quando estão
em sala de aula eu busco o erro no mundo
do empreendedorismo a gente costuma
falar de mvp né mínimo produto viável no
mundo do palhaço aprender
ou seja no mundo do aprender e do
turismo
nós escrevemos isso é errado pra gente é
o melhor carro possível porque o palhaço
aprendi a metodologia o palhaço ele não
entra na sala de aula sem pedir licença
ele faz a mesma coisa que um palhaço do
hospital faz
e aí quando a gente fala de melhor é
impossível a gente escreveu encerrado
e aí não sei se vocês pararam para
pensar mas a gente não costuma colocar
junto melhor erro eo melhor é impossível
tem algumas características ele é
solucionável é identificável ele é
contextualizado
eu vou começar de trás pra frente pra
frente que jatos ou tô errado
contextualizado porquê porque ele
precisa fazer parte daquele universo
porque se não é só mais uma gracinha e
toda gracinha pode ser uma desgraça e
aluno que faz palhaçada todo o professor
tem o erro também tem que ser
identificável é quando a criança olha e
fala pedra a entende tá errado e aí o
erro passa a ser solucionada vel' porque
ela pega o palhaço encaminha o palhaço
relação em direção ao acerto e aí
estudos provam que muitas vezes quando a
gente está ensinando alguém a gente está
aprendendo também eu já acumula mais de
mil horas de voo como palhaço
empreendedor e eu costumo falar que o
espetáculo é aprendizagens as pessoas me
perguntam você entra em sala e faz uma
apresentação não o espetáculo é
aprendizagem quando a criança se
desenvolve identificando um erro do
palhaço conduzindo elaborando
mentalmente o conteúdo pra que ele
aprenda e para que ela explique de uma
forma compreensível e pra que ela possa
criar empatia com alguém que é assim
como ela muitas vezes o erro palhaço
apresenta é o erro das crianças e eu já
tenho acumulado muitas histórias
muitos momentos bonitos meu sonho é
levar o aprender e do turismo para
muitas escolas
hoje eu já conto com outras quatro
palhaços aprendê do hras que me ajudam a
divulgar essa idéia em duas escolas uma
delas a minha esposa está aqui e meu
sonho é acumular cada vez mais histórias
bonitas como a história de uma menina do
sexto ano que um dia quando eu
apresentei um erro pra ela ela me disse
uma frase que eu tenho certeza que
muitos de vocês já ouviram e que me deu
um frio na barriga ela disse como você é
burro
naquele momento o menino dentro de mim
gritou eu voltei no tempo naquela fração
de segundos
eu olhei pra mim diante do quadro negro
pra mim a professora
o que eu não sabia é que naquele momento
o nariz de palhaço
essa máscara maravilhosa já tinha me
curado eu olhei pra mim falei ficar
calmo
vai dar tudo certo olhei para a minha
professora perdoei o erro dela porque
ele me trouxe aqui hoje direito a menina
sorri e disse para ela o seguinte burro
eu não eu sou especialista em erro
nesse momento todo aquele olhar
julgamento da menina foi embora elas o
rio me ajudou a aprender o que era
preciso que era muito mais do que estava
no caderno ela foi embora feliz e eu
também porque naquele momento foi a
defesa da minha tese e
como especialista na arte de errar a
mensagem que eu gostaria de deixar para
vocês é que a escola precisa tanto de
palhaços quanto de professores
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]